hello guys my name is Jenna welcome to
episode 6 of Sparky Engine series where
we're going to create an engine from
scratch in C++ so last time we
implemented some at fors
writes and 4x4 matrices and they were
all nice now one thing I do want to
point out is I saw a comment and of
course I need to fix this in my
perspective matrix I was returning see
so let's not return C which is a float
let's return result so let's quickly go
into that so this is on the perspective
and let's return result ok again we
would have caught this straightaway if
we actually had shaders and whatnot but
I don't think I made any other silly
errors like that cool anyway back to
business let's go ahead and talk about
shaders okay so she odors are
essentially ways to program our graphics
cards when we send when we send any kind
of data to the graphics card so well
like here's an array full of vertices
and indices and texture coordinates and
textures and everything the graphics
card has no idea what to do with this
information so we need to tell it catch
all the stuff I'm giving you and do
something with it
okay preferably draw it to the screen in
certain ways as well so so what we need
to do is set up a system so that we can
write our own shaders okay because
they're going to be very very important
for games okay and graphics so to do
that we need to do a few things so
firstly shaders are usually written as
separate files you don't have to write
them in separate files you can survive
them as strings but usually you would
write them as separate files so we
currently have no capability in our game
engine to actually read files and we
need that so the first thing we're going
to do is write a file reading class so
under source I want to make a new folder
called utils we're just going to stand
for utilities and then underneath that I
make a header file called file utils dot
H okay and I want to pragma once that
the stuff we'll need probably will be
let's see so I guess we'll just can pour
stuff
we need them yeah so we'll start off
with this but it'll be namespace Sparky
and then I guess I'll go we just leave
it like that I don't think I'll put into
another name space like utils or
whatever we'll just we'll leave it here
so mmm so to read a file I'm going to
return a string a standard string okay
where we will let's see so we'll call it
read file I'm going to call it lowercase
so okay I'm not log it okay so let me
quickly mention this anything that is a
function anything that is not part of a
class anything that is not a method I'm
going to write using this naming
convention okay where instead of having
camel case like this we just have
underscores in between words and
everything is lowercase okay we use this
same thing in window when we made our
functions like all these callbacks you
can see that they're not they're not
parallel class they are actually part of
the class they're friends but they're
treated the same way as if there were
simple functions okay because there's
actually what we had them as before okay
so all these callbacks are simply
functions okay essentially right because
they're not actually part of the class
so that being said let's go ahead and
write this method or write this function
so it's going to take in a file path so
that's the file that will be reading one
thing we will need to include is string
of course if we want strings and we'll
also have to use it bigger we'll be
using a few different things but let's
go ahead and create this so how are we
going to read files well you can do file
reading a number of different ways we're
going to do it using just a sample the
standard C like wire writing files using
a file the reason is this is much faster
than I have stream and I'll actually I
might actually do a video comparing the
two because it just might be an
interesting thing to do I don't know if
I have time but um this is much faster
than actually
then actually using if' stream so yeah
so you can there is that the I guess the
main c++ way of doing things would be by
including app stream and then using iof
stream file or whatever and then you can
take in your file path and whatnot but
this is much much faster so let's set
that equal to F open which will open our
file so we're going to go ahead and so
file path is obviously the file path and
then mode so mode is essentially certain
flags we can set to how we want to open
this file so we want to open it for
readings only which is where we're going
to specify our and we want it to be a
text file we want to tell her that this
is not a binary file or anything this is
a text file okay now if we do it as a
read it in as a text file the difference
really is the fact that it will it'll
use proper line endings and it will
recognize proper line endings binary
files of course certainly have line
endings right they're just a bunch of
bytes but text files do okay so when we
read out when when we read our shaders
is really important that we actually
have line endings because if you look at
a stat if I'd like if I were to write a
simple shader over here for example the
first thing usually in the shader is
version right so if you have something
like a version 334
right and then of course you have your
main your main for your shadow right
then if there are no proper line endings
this will be on one line and suddenly
it'll be part of the hash and there's
just it will just get invalid stuff so
you need to make sure that your line
endings are pristine
so to ensure that we're going to make
sure that we read it in as a text file
okay next up next up we actually need to
see how long how large the file is right
we want to see how long it is so in
order to do that we actually have to
navigate to the end of the file using F
sake so the file that we'll be
navigating to the end of is file again
this is this isn't written as a
object-oriented file thing right so in
C++ them you know if this was an
object-oriented file
like class we could do something like
file dot C or something like that but
because it's AC library we can't
actually do that we have to use the old
procedural way so if you guys confused
as to why this is looking weird or
whatever and you've come from Java this
is why okay because this isn't like a
C++ thing with objects it's just to see
just to see library that's all that's
all it is so we want to go to the very
end of the file so we pass in seek end
and then once we've done that we can
actually retrieve the length okay which
is typically an unsigned long so to
retrieve the length we can just use FTL
and in the file all right and that'll
give us then I'm revisor of yeah buts
that it's read essentially okay cool so
now that's done in fact FTL might
actually give us the number of
characters that's read because this
isn't a binary file let's let's find out
yes
so if it okay yeah so for binary streams
it is the number of eyes but not for
text streams so yeah keep that in mind
cool anyway mmm next next up so now that
we've got the length and the reason we
figured out the length by the way is
that okay so few things it is actually
the number of bytes okay and the reason
this is important is because we can now
make a character array that will
actually we'll use to read into this so
if I make a character around I'll call
this data because it's the wrong data
I'm going to pass in length which will
be remember one character is one by so
length and then the plus one is here
because I want a termination character
at the end of it to tell it that this
string is terminated okay which is
important when we when we want to use it
as a normal string so you'll see okay
cool so now what we have to do is use
memset to actually set all of this to
zero
okay because we F tell is a touch broken
and it'll give us some extra bytes
essentially so there will be a problem
okay um yes so let's see what am i doing
in mint okay and then this will be
length plus one okay so we've set
everything to zero and now we can go
ahead and seek okay so now we want to
reset the seek position so that we're
back to the beginning because we went to
the end so that we could see the file
length but now we go back to the
beginning and we want to read in into
data
let's element size one the size of the
count will be our length and then the
file that we're reading it possibly file
again I don't know I feel like file
should be the first parameter here but
it's not whatever it's just the way it
is once we read all that we can close
the file and then we can go ahead and
create our strength which is going to be
our result and we'll just go ahead and
pass and file like this so not file um
data like that alright as soon as we've
copied that data across into the string
we can delete it but we need to delete
it otherwise it'll remain in memory and
then we can simply return our result
okay done so there we go that is our
read file thing it should work pretty
well if we want to test it we can
quickly go to main and go ahead and say
over here I'll just type in what will
include
source utils file utils we'll go ahead
and string file equals oops
read file this will be I will just read
the current file so main dot CPP and
we'll output it okay cool and then we
can just return so we're going to do the
rest of that stuff and or in fact let me
just grab we're not doing that anymore
okay
I thought we still system forcing at the
end but I guess we're not so system
cause alright so we run this okay so one
thing you will get is we should probably
make sure that we're returning a value
as well but one thing you will get is a
basically a deprecation warning where
it'll be like lul don't use f open its
insecure use F open s which is is the
secure option
whatever all this hatred will be
projected towards us we can fix that if
you go into it actually tells us how to
fix it as well but you can see it says
to disable deprecation use CRT secure no
warnings okay so if we right click go to
properties and then under C++ and
preprocessor under preprocessor
preprocessor definitions where we define
glue static we also want to include or
define secure CIT secure no warnings
okay there we go and now that error will
go away so if we build it now we
shouldn't get a problem and if we run it
you can see it should read our file in
its entirety all the way over here now
one of the things that might pop up in
questions is why did I use the mem set
to set all the bytes to zero if I get
rid of that you'll see artifacts and
stuff at the end okay because yeah just
because it the way that we read files
and just because of the way that it
doesn't know where the termination
character is unless is 0 so if we do
this it will ensure that it reads our
file properly ok
or rather create
sit properly into a string okay cool
so there we go so now we can read files
yay
so let's talk about shaders shaders
share to share this so in graphics I'm
going to make a new item because hard to
believe everything on one class and
graphics but anyway launders approaching
shader dot H so let's go into window dot
H and copy our namespace stuff pragma
once this will be in the graphics
namespace of course thanks Visual Studio
it's not like I wanted to have it on the
same line or anything
alright so class shader so to show you
the classes are pretty pretty cool the
only thing this is going to do is manage
our shader for us so it's going to load
our shader in so from a file right we've
already got something that can load
files in fact that you will include that
so include utils file utils right it's
also going to manage sending data to the
shader and enabling and disabling
shaders ok and storing uniform locations
as well which we'll cover so the first
thing that we should have right is and
let's include glue as well sorry GL glue
right is a unsigned int ok which is our
shader ok so this is our OpenGL shader
ID so once we create a shader open just
gives us a number essentially an
unsigned int so that we can refer to
that shader later ok if we want to do so
I've kind of like the same thing that we
did with where are we in files right
where we we had a file and we had to
pass in that pointer every time we
wanted to do something with a file same
thing in OpenGL right we have to pass in
this shader ID every time we want to do
something that concerns the shader so
that's our ID ok and then what I'll do
here is a blur will take in a shader so
when we load in a shader typically we
want to load in usually at least
vertex and fragment shader of course
there are the shaders like geometry and
tessellation shaders we're not going to
cover them just yet because we need them
for now but we'll probably the engine
will probably support them eventually
just not now so we'll have to file parts
will have the vertex path or the path to
the vertex shader and then the path to
the fragment shader okay that'll be our
main constructor will also have a
destructor not sure if we'll use out but
we probably will and let's see and then
I guess we'll have like enable and
disable which will just they'll be
basically just an abstraction for GL use
program which will use this current
shader
okay anyway this is our basic shader
class we'll add a lot more in a minute
but let's go ahead and start
implementing it so I see a CPP file
called shader all right fantastic
so let's include shader let's include
our namespace so let's our the
constructor cons char
frag third path comes sure fried part
okay so we probably wouldn't get this to
actually load it I mean we could but I
don't think so
so I'm going to make a private method
here which is kind of loading we'll just
have a separate method for it it'll
return the ID and we'll call it
something like the load and then it'll
take in other file parts I'm actually
going to keep the file paths here and
I'm going to make them up here so we'll
have vert path and store em the path and
my path the reason I'm keeping them up
here is for debugging purposes okay
because when you get an error or a
certain shader fails to compile or not
even that but you're trying to set a
uniform and the shaders incorrect it can
help to see which shader is throwing
that out
so by having this stuff here you will be
able to recall that let me just make
sure let's ignore that compassion okay
so that's why I'm doing that
and then we'll have load we might
disable the stuff and release builds or
something it's not really going to harm
us too much if we don't throw why are
you mad oh okay
we can fix that so fragged path is a
third path is going to set be set to
that path and fry path is going to be
set to drag bar all right yay so let's
move on
um okay so we're going to set M shader
ID am shader equal to I'll call it MJ
righty we'll say that equal to load okay
let's go back let's go back okay cool so
this is where the fun begins because
we're going to actually load our stuff
now so uh why did I come here to change
this of course
loading shaders is just just a just a
ton of fun really okay
I'm saying this somewhat I'm
unenthusiastically because it's actually
all that fun it's a bunch of boilerplate
code so to load a shader let's talk
about this in rough detail so what we're
going to need first of all is to
generate a program so under GL unions
I'm going to go ahead and say people is
something like results or I think I'll
just put program though because it's a
bit better and then I'm going to call GL
create program okay
so program is basically all of our
shaders into one kind of program right
so as I mentioned Chad is a related
program the graphics card they require
there are many different there are many
different types of shaders such as um
well you know vertex fragment
tessellation geometry all these
different shaders but there
individually they don't they don't
really do anything you need at least a
vertex and fragment shader okay the
vertex does stuff per vertex the
fragment does stuff per fragment which
is usually per pixel so the idea with
that is we need both of them to function
and obviously for both of them to
function we need to link both of them
into our program okay so we want to make
a program out of our shaders and then
this will generate a new program ID so
that we can start creating our program
out of the actual shaders that we pass
pass in here so that is the idea so
let's go ahead and create a vertex
shader I'll call the vertex and then
we'll pass in jail shader vertex or what
is this jail vertex shader all right
we'll do the exact same thing for the
fragment shader all right and then we'll
go ahead and set the chatter sauce so we
need to actually when you actually read
it so let's go ahead and read it so SUT
string let's just say the sauce is going
to be read file and we're going to read
is the file path which is just M read
path not IBM but realized what is it the
third path oh my goodness
ah because I'm pressing on thing okay so
we've got our vertex source we're going
to have a our fragment source okay and
then what
let's say well what are we oh ha this is
actually good I'm really glad this
happened this is why it's important to
not define pointers here because when
you do it for multiple things like this
each of these actually has to have a an
asterisk next to it okay very important
and you can see that fixed our error
okay so you can either do that or I'm
going to be I'm just going to do it
differently I'm going to actually
declare them on different lines just
because but yeah give that mind each
thing in a row needs a needs a an
asterisk next to this is a pointer okay
because otherwise it makes the other
thing just one constant character not an
array of constant characters not a
pointer to to that okay great so next up
we need to actually load in our trader
sources so GL shader source okay we're
going to pass in so what the first thing
it wants is the shader which is vertex
let's chatter ID right then it wants the
count so just just one and then what it
wants is a GL char of strings and
there's two pointers in there so we need
to pass in the address of this vertex
source on Versalles see string all right
cool we might have to just what does
that apply to again I think that will
fix it no we'll figure out in a minute
let's just finish this line um and then
we need the let's see what else we need
I'll just know okay cool so why are you
screaming at me
come sharp that's louder the v1 run out
of names soon there's going to be that I
don't know why I made it a reference
lull and then we'll pass in last okay
in fact we could probably just simplify
this a lot if we did something like this
okay and then we can just pass in that
okay and then we'll do the same for for
this okay now these guys are in here we
can actually compile the chatter by
calling GL compile shader and the trader
will be filing is vertex okay assuming
this works we're all good but
unfortunately if we have any errors in
our shader such as like syntax errors
for example we misplaced a like we've
got to close the scope or something
we're missing a bracket also I don't
know just syntax errors or whatever we
want to be able to see if the shader
compilation failed because of one of
these errors so what we need to do is
actually retrieve the log so basically
we want to get the result of whether or
not our shader succeeds so if I just
make a an integer here called result and
then I get the shader so if I just type
in jail get shader IV I can get from the
vertex shader the compile status or
really anything I want so this is what
this is like a property I want to get
and then of course we're going to find
out what the status of that is by
putting it into result okay so now we
can do something like if result equals
false or jail files we can handle it
okay so let's go ahead and get the log
so in slang for
jail in two lengths will get the shower
probably need much of this actually will
see their info log length yeah I don't
think we need all this um let's dump it
into a vector of vector of chars we need
to include that tournament as well so
we'll dump it into here we'll just
create that so it doesn't resize it and
it knows how big it is so GL shader info
log we're going to grab our vertex our
length how length again because that's
what once um and then the pointer to the
first element okay so one thing we'll
need to do quickly is include vector
okay cool so there you go
yeah okay anyway once we've got all that
which probably printed so we can go
ahead and print it just I'll print it
just to see out now again we'll have our
logging system soon eventually which
will print all this stuff for us so we
won't really need to do this this is
just temporary so error 0 and line okay
okay and then let's delete our shadow
because it's it's dead
and then I don't know we can return
something like that's an unsigned in so
if we turn something like negative one
started sort of myself as an outside it
if we turn 0 then it means that we
failed okay we got also throw an
exception but that wouldn't be the best
of ideas okay
next up on the menu we do the exact same
thing for the fragment shader so
fragments fragments what else
white y'see yep yes that's fine
okay good so let's just replace all this
the fragment we might print something
like failed to comply also fail to
compile fragment shader
maybe another end line and then the
actual message so we can do something
like that
there we go except it's case of a big
vertex alright good so we're looking
better now we're looking good all we
need to do now is not delete the vertex
shader all we need to do now is um
basically link all of them so we've got
two separate compiled shaders vertex and
fragment are now done right where it
needs to really do anything with them
anymore what we do need to do is attach
the shader to our program
okay so we're passing program and then
the shadow such as vertex this is going
to attach them to our program because
remember they're going to work together
now if our flow is going to be the
vertex shader is going to then progress
onto the fragment shader at runtime
right so we need to link them so that it
knows where it is then we do need to
actually link them we validate them and
finally that's it we can just return
them so every 10 program we don't need
the actual shaders anymore so we can
delete them by the way so we can go GL
delete shader of vertex and fragment so
let's go ahead do that and we're done
okay there you go beautiful shared code
hopefully all this works this is still
giving us somewhat an error
expected a what oh I forgot the column
okay and there we go so that's all good
yep so and then that's get set and get
set to load so now let's go ahead and
actually create our enable
not ten so GL use program shader and by
that I mean M header ID
make sure that's Const popin based arts
for disabled and also that 2-0 all right
there you go done so that's the basic
idea for a shader so if we go back here
let's just becoming such a mess
um so let's probably clean all this out
we don't need any of the VEX anymore we
will need that but whatever um let's
yeah whatever bro
we'll keep this here I guess okay so
we'll get rid of immediate mode keep
that or erase that okay so let's test
out whether or not this worked so
include graphics shaded of H okay we'll
go ahead and create a new shader object
so shader shader will take in the file
paths so right now I'll put them into
let's see I'll put them into believe
them in source and we'll make shaders
because I'm sorry so shaders you'll have
to copy them to the you have to copy
them out into the binary direction with
a binary binary directory when you
actually give the game somewhat like if
you run an outsider Visual Studio if you
want inside Visual Studio you can it's
fine if it's in source so will not make
it a sympathy file so we'll make
something called like basic Talbert and
basic dot frag okay
so in both of these I'm going to set the
version to 334 and then all the
fragments are older the better shader
okay so the vertex shader will do a
number of things a it will take in an
attribute called so we'll make sure that
it's in the first location here it'll be
called position okay that's all we
that's all we'll take in for now
there'll be a uniform mat for sopr
matrix which is the projection matrix
and we'll do stuff like view matrix and
model matrix okay these will be set to
the identity matrix by default because I
don't want to make the mandatory whereas
we do need a projection matrix
in fact I'll even set that to just one
another way um we won't use that for now
so we've got our position right so what
we do we want to set is jail have I just
forgotten how to write shaders GL is it
a jail vertex position is that is no no
I've just had a complete brain freeze no
it's not is it
oh it's GL position well sorry my brain
just froze
okay back to this so GL position will
set equal to PR
matrix times possession now if we are
really nice than we are we can ignore
this for now just to get the minimum
amount and then ball pass in the
projection matrix that's done our
fragment shader a bit different
where's my hash version 334
Boyd mean okay so this will actually do
the opposite so louse location 0 just
means it's in there but this just means
it's in the it defines where the rather
where the variables location is because
anything that is in or out isn't
actually like it's either imported from
somewhere or exported from somewhere so
in this case we set layout location to 0
so that we can actually pass in an
attribute to the shader at this location
whereas if we don't know the location we
have to retrieve it because we can't be
guaranteed that it will be 0 every time
for example in this case it will be
because we've set it to that so as much
as like that you can also set layout
location to uniforms but I believe that
only in original 4 or above and I don't
want I wanna maintain compatibility with
probably about 330 so I'm not going to
use that but that is also very useful if
you
said Laos from uniforms but we're going
to one we're not going to do that so out
back for color okay this can even be a
float or a back three doesn't really
care too much which is nice but will a
put the color to be something like pink
for example okay so rgba alright cool
there we go so those are two functional
shaders which should do exactly what we
tell them to so let's go back here now
what was our um was our immediate mode
rendering stuff let me really find that
pocket core source I'm literally on
github right now to try to find out what
I typed um main does it be okay I just
wanted the so here they are let's copy
them back in so I'm giving this here
because I'm about to find that stuff so
we're in shade is basic dots vert and
then shaders basic dot Frank great so if
I go ahead and let's just get rid of
them now we're on this bill there is a
giant result redefinition really oh yes
so I will just um get rid of the second
one - okay
unresolved stuff read file huh
why you unresolved me and shared it okay
yep so let's make sure we have the
destructor okay and by the way in the
destructor we should probably put
something like GL delete program em
shader ID
all right probably a good thing to do
okay um so read file is mad arts its
multiplying multiple times okay I see so
annoying um yes where are we where are
we
where's my refile method no no no you
tell us vitals so why we define
multiplies that's mine we shouldn't be
well should I include it I wouldn't in
Maine okay let's just let's here it is
for now we'll face out later
where am i using this thing read file
already defined where
let's just say I shouldn't rush it that
should be included anywhere that's weird
have I made something I made something
important probably but weird oh well if
we built into a Klaus will go away so
we'll probably make a quick pass for
this because I can't before the facing
this right now therefore make it a strut
because why not well no we'll make it a
plus I don't want to be grating strux
without was absolutely zero stuff that
that's not going to go down too well
alright okay so it should work okay um
okay so it couldn't find the file
it seems let's go into main
so why let's see it shadows basic to
avert shade it's basic of that it's
there hmm let's quickly check this out
all right you where are you
let's go down here okay what's that path
shade is basically that that seems fine
right shade is basic to that and yet
you're annoying
why you so annoying
okay so okay let's say
let's properly do this so the problem
with this is that it will get deleted or
okay I'll explain in a minute
so third source string okay so the
problem with this is if so what we were
doing was we were reading the file which
returns us a string and then we're
getting C string and synthesis like long
this out of this original sed string is
not being used anymore so I'm going to
delete it and what happens with that is
that C string is just a pointer to what
is in here and if that gets gone then so
does that and we have massive problems
everywhere so we want to basically
retain this so if we do this we
shouldn't get such a problem because it
won't be destroyed it's right away okay
important stuff anyway that that should
help fix that I'm still not sure why add
can't find our path because it should
oh no whoops that's my problem
I know why I can't find the path because
I'm an idiot
make sure you have source at the front
okay so good um well actually not good
really okay this is this is not good
this isn't actually not true
lay out location does not require
version 410 this is bad okay something
is something is up and I forgot what it
was but it's not it's not that it's
lying to me
it does that sometimes by the way shared
is will sometimes lie to you don't
listen to them it's probably I'm it's
probably to do with my compilation mmm
if sheet is lying to you you know that
you've messed something up so vertex
vertex vertex so the vertex rate of one
so what's wrong here fragment Frank
sauce fragment fragment fragment
fragment fragment hmm everything looks
good
jail fragment shader hmm weird what is
wrong with this crap program [ __ ]
fedexes yes there's really a typo
somewhere in here it's a way so I hate
this initial creation of shader code
delete shade of vertex that's right
dry mint Prime in fragments Ragman again
let's say this is a good way to your
quickly check yeah seems legit is that
legit I think it's legit so why is it
crying let's quickly check this Oh fine
just give me like friggin HTML
wait does it have it does have backslash
ends good so it does have that frog is
correct oh oh hang on a minute out back
for color is what I meant to say I love
how I caught that in the rather than
actually reading the shader I caught it
in the frigging like in like here in
this tiny space I was like well that's
wrong okay cool so this should work now
weird how it starts lying to you though
it's like well you want to use layout
bro
that's like version 410 so I don't know
why that's a bit weird but anyway we've
got no errors now good now it's good
that we had a few errors because we
managed to test the error checking
system that way which is always good so
now that we've got that we should be
able to enable our shader and then do
cool stuff like let's test this out so
let's be like I want a it is going to be
long it so have you guys ready for that
G all float vertices equals and I want
to set it equal to this and yeah we'll
just one-liner penalize it so this is
where I wanted to have my my original
vertices so I wouldn't have to really
think too much so we're basically I want
to just do this so going or in fact if
these are aligned which they now are I
can just be like well thank you let's
take a few of these
all right cool so go we've got four
vertices now we need indices or six
vertices to make a rectangle so let's
see I could just copy that one really so
that and then that and then we need one
more which i think is that and then we
need the first one all right
so well this is just what is up and what
is here okay I'm just going to be
aligned everything that looks pretty
good I'm not even going to double check
that I don't really care
we'll see result so we need to create
this stuff so we've got that bind vertex
arrays we don't even need a vertex right
goodbye
ah the Bo GL bind or GL Jen buffers
I want one buffer please hmm I want to
bind you in a non-aggressive way ray
buffer and V Bo and then I want to
buffer daughter so GL array buffer so
I'm giving it the data now so I've
generated a bit of generated an Open GL
buffer which is just like an array right
full of data and then this is the data
on giving it so it's going to be size of
Vettes so this size of it wants it
invites so we can just say size of
vertices the data is going to be
vertices and then the usage is going to
be just gel static draw cool now this
data is now in OpenGL which is fantastic
but we need to also transmit this data
to the shaders so that it knows what to
do with it so we can do that by using a
vertex attribute pointer now if you use
one of these that is a trick pointer if
you use one of these outside of a vertex
array it's kind of global so just keep
that in mind so when we actually make
this and we actually have a proper
renderer it will use a vertex array
mm but this is just an example of course
so let's see what it was this one again
please help me
so index zero size three so it's three
because there's three components to
which each like each vertex ah type GL
floats normalized jail false stride
we can probably indistinct both of these
at zero and then GL enable their tags at
rib array a lot of stuff to type there
at index zero okay and then if we do
that and we draw to the arrays with sex
hopefully this will not work of course
because of course I've forgotten
something
question is what oh I didn't even have
with my shader so yes I did okay what
did I do
VBA let's bring this down downstairs so
it's a bit close link they seemed legit
I am drawing my beautiful raise the
buffer is bound vertices are correct
agenda buffers hmm
everything should be working and so I've
missed something have I missed something
I probably have stream help me out GL
flow to the three yep
seems pretty legit hmm
hmm I don't know this seems pretty it
seems fine let's try putting into a VA
oh it doesn't really it doesn't really
need one though so I'll be surprised if
this works
where's this once yep hmm interesting
what am i shade is saying they want a
vac for position at location zero and
that's yet okay well oh hang on a minute
why do I have GL array buffer here
that'll be why yay oh my goodness that's
silly
that code was in there anyway my
goodness okay so we don't need this
anyway okay let's go do that okay there
we go
so we should be getting a pink thing on
the screen so it's a bit weird um done
so anyway now we've got that
let's try metal around with the
projection matrix and see what will
happen so the first thing I want to do
is if we are doing something like a
projection matrix and I make a mouth for
called author and I set that equal to
Matt for author or ortho graphic and I
do something like 0 1609 near and far
we'll just set to like 1 by 0 miser but
it's like that and I want to pass it
into the shader I have to do something
like GL shader sorry GL uniform
4fv
no no sorry there's a special matrix for
it matrix for FV location being well a I
need the shadows location so that's a
bit annoying let's quickly just make
this public for now remind me to turn
that off later
so shade a dot I need Eid I need the
accounts which is one because I want one
matrix for transpose no and then the
value which is just going to be mat for
dot elements not thrown on that four
elements or third elements and then we
should probably get rid of geek home as
well anyway I have to do this whole
thing right and then I have to be like
wait hang on no well I don't actually
need that there I need the location of
there because I was like where do I put
the location of the shader and then I'm
like well I don't need that at all so GL
guess uniform location PR matrix you
want the shader as well don't you yeah
okay cool so now we've got this big
thing here which sets our matrix
appropriately so if we go back to our
basic divert and uncomment the P R
matrix we should see
this right so clearly our projection
matrix worked and that actually does
look like it worked
so if we go into Maine and we make this
let's just say 15 and then we'll come
back in - okay let's redefine these
vertices as being something like so I'll
make the first one at 0 0 0 then I'll
make one at like 1500 and then I'll make
1 at 0 15 0 that's our triangle in fact
well let's just draw a triangle well so
let's maybe make this at 8 or something
so I'm making it just below the things
we can see if it's working and yeah it
looks like it's working right so there's
our wonderful I am unfortunately going
back against the spirit of the rectangle
I probably shouldn't be doing that so
let's fix this up quickly what we 16
right so this 12 okay so this should be
1/2 a rectangle right absolutely not not
0 model b9 right so let's maybe go 3 and
6
what am i doing for 12 0 no 4 12 4 3 6 3
no no wait
okay um let's leave this on 3 and then
put this one up to 6 I don't know what
I'm doing
it's half of our rectangle let's do the
same thing
it's only that only that and we need
this heel okay there we go
no well yes I just need to actually draw
it
ah
the guessing games not working out for
me it should be turn 2 2 2 2 2 2 2 2 a 2
second one yay okay anyway that's the
idea um we've got a rectangle now yeah
so the problem is I doing stuff like
this is a bit annoying okay we want to
abstract out and make the shader do that
for us so let's do that
so in shader which is over here by the
way people who are watching this on
YouTube can you please put the kick
could you please post a comment about
your feelings regarding these long
episodes because I know that if you're
in if because this is being
live-streamed and for people on the
stream long stream is good like everyone
seems to like long streams but if each
episode of Sparky is like an hour or
more I feel that maybe people won't like
that as much as like maybe 20 minute
videos so we'll see because I could try
and split that up if you guys want but
it's up to you I mean I'm happy to do
this it's actually easier for me if I
don't split it up but anyway we'll see
am I still recording this yes good okay
um so we'll go ahead and it's getting
late as well as freaking 6:00 okay we
need to accelerate this okay so anyway
I'll make this private and then what I
typically like to do is what I typically
what I typically like to do is actually
pretty much
make a method for setting all kinds of
uniforms in here so I could have
something like void set uniform mat for
for example alright and that is our
example with matrix and then all this
has to take in is the actual math for
that we do want to do so we do need to
take in a name right which is just going
to be like a string of basically what we
want to set it to right as in what you
know what what the name of the uniform
variable is and then we just need to
take in in this case a mat for so const
mat for what am i doing
const mat for matrix right yeah we just
would do something like something as
simple as that
and will include maths as well
okay and then if we want to go ahead and
and there's so many of these like if we
want to set uniform one F or one eye
this is basically what I typically do
right and then over here we take into
float I really need to take floats in by
conference so floats the value in value
you know all these crazy things 2 F 3 F
so for our vectors and we can get these
to actually take in stuff like maths
back to obviously these will be comped
mouths back to vector and then Mass
Effect 3 vector and then back for vector
yeah and we can do all that fun stuff
and I think that's probably about it for
now
so all this cool stuff that we can do
that's why I typically do right because
then we can just simply call the
appropriate method and we're all good so
let's quickly implement all these
they're very short methods they'll be
like one line edge oh and we also need a
big one which is GL what is it int I
think it's just in yep because negative
one can be a value so G so it's assigned
end of shader sorry Lauren shader and
this is just called gas uniform okay so
this gets the uniform location of
alligators folders get uniform location
all right actually that's the same as
the opengl one is now is it with man
no it's GLK okay so we'll just have to
get uniform location okay
and this this will be the just a name
okay and then this this is just good for
arm getting the actual location of a
uniform which we need for these in one's
okay I will make it public I will make
it private because I don't think people
should be using it otherwise they're
doing something wrong because this
shadow should be doing everything and if
not you can just use up in jails method
if you really want to okay cool so
shader so here are all of our lovelies
all of our nice uniform stuff okay
so GL set a jail uniform
1f so location is going to be get
uniform location name and then the value
is going to be value all right pretty
good what is where is our set location
did I implement that at all I don't
think I did where is it I'll get here
for migration that's what I used why you
mad why you mad
let's implement that I think I did
implement that okay so this will be
simple now this is a slow operation
getting the uniform location it's very
slow so we will cache these eventually
I'm not going to do this episode I'll do
it in the upcoming optimization episode
and maintenance episode which I believe
will be about episode 10 ish so I'll go
bother with that now because well time
is going on this is a long video as it
is but yes this is a very slow operation
so you will want to cache these
locations anyway um GL get uniform
location name so right now we'll just do
this um M shader ID okay there we go
done so anyway this you can copy and
paste wherever you like and literally
all you'll need changes like this stuff
well I don't know why that's an error
but whatever what is this - F why is
this in our it's confused is very
confused but that's all right we'll
we'll let it be confused vector dot X
vector dot y
vectored I said now even vectors
confused it's just the whole thing is
just very confused that's all right
remember children intellisense arrows
aren't real arrows ok and finally we
have this now this is a bit different um
ok let's see let's just copy this
because that's what we did
so back in shader so matrix dot elements
and that's it my goodness it's just
forgotten about this one's like oh no
you want this one like nah
well actually I'm an idiot but I guess
ha I guess we can just blame everything
on intellisense anyway I mean Intel so
this is Intel sense isn't bad or
anything it's just sometimes it's a bit
confusing and sometimes it's misleading
but usually it's good it's better than
anything else that exists anyway this is
because I didn't change this all right
everything else looks pretty good so the
hood is good let's go ahead and go to
main let's quickly go ahead and say make
sure you have it's shader enabled by the
way if you don't then you try and pass
the uniform it'll yell at you so if we
set uniform at for now we should be able
to do is be like I want the bhpr matrix
to be set to my ortho that's it right
now if we run this it should work it did
work cool so there we go that's pretty
much it that's gonna wrap up this
episode um one other thing well I guess
we'll test out another cool thing um in
fact let's do this let's go back into
basic of it let's grab these ones let's
multiply
let's multiply them here okay so
obviously these are won by default if
we're on this now should be the exact
same results fantastic
but back in Maine if I were to go ahead
and shade adults set uniform for to
something like Matt four sorry to
something like I don't know the model
matrix so we can change well model view
in this case wouldn't matter but I want
to translate something if we call
translation and not translate really
about rotate its rotation I don't know
why named like this but whatever
Veck 3 something like that whatever are
actually little sub rendering it that we
want is that what you want why are you
so sad okay that I mean that seemed to
work I'm not going to complain
I think that's working let's try a
rotation around the z-axis
five forty five degrees hmm yay okay so
it seems to be working right um which is
good so there you go the weird offset is
because of a number of things but it's
what it works which is good it's
basically because it's not in the center
so really what we should have done is
I'm not going to do it now but in fact I
will do it now let's pop let's pop this
back to zero zero so we'll subtract
everything by four it looks like and
three for the other thing so now it is
being rounded there and the rotation
should be working the rotation should be
against the corner which is right here
all right and it looks like that's fine
so if I go 90 degrees my only work but
you guys get the point okay and if I
want to get into that particular place
I'll probably just leave the translation
in there we wanted to how much was it it
was four and three
hmm okay there we go yay cool fantastic
so let's try setting some more shader
things so shaded I'll set uniform for
v4f for example we can set the color so
we can be like Cole or I'll just call it
Cole or I'll be extra confusing and pull
of the Australian spilling color to go
back for so maybe like 0.20 went through
like Sam is out clear color basically I
guess that'll be a good way to test it
I'm probably change that clear call it
so why in a minute we'll go to a
fragment shader be like a uniform back
for color I love that naming the best
day ever so now should be invisible
either that or it's not working but
invisible also floats my boat so let's
set this to one to make this background
white I kind of like why more than black
I think okay fantastic it's almost like
we flipped the colors but yeah all the
way used to be pink so we can set colors
now which is good and let's do something
like shade adult set uniform 2 vs a lot
that too if this last thing we'll check
and will be something like light
position or something also that - like
what's the center of a screen well I
guess we'll just set it to like 84.5
will be as close to the center as we can
be well that is the center but anyway
we'll set that we'll go into one of our
shaders hmm we'll be like uniform
affects your lights position and then we
can be like distance is or intensity
Eagles like 1 divided by a length of we
need the length of the position as well
so this is probably becoming quite big
but out back for pause pause equals
position length of pause - lights
position times intensity okay well um
what's wrong with this let's quickly
diagnose it um it just - it's just too
bright that's an option let's hit the
click a lot of 0 mm hang on a minute
yeah let's just set the click Auto zero
or something not that's not white oh
okay that's bad that means there's an
arrow large position vector is good it
might be this but we've got narrow
though so that's always fun um where is
our infant vector light position that's
correct right
it's vector oh this is a lot of bacteria
yeah there we go okay all good in the
hood
why was that shader error it would have
been right let me close all this stuff
it would have been Ryan um maybe I
didn't notice console yeah it would have
been a trader error
hang on yeah it is maybe I needed to
like pop up I met a message box being
like yeah to scare me or something but I
don't know let's try this cool lighting
so there you go
let's go let's get rid of that hideous
color okay so there we go so we've got a
bit of lighting now I might just make it
black to be honest or we can just leave
it as weiss but then we'll just get rid
of that yay okay cool
so there we go we've got a basic light
that's not the center oh what's wrong
with this why is it not in the center
what's ow oh wait no that should be
correct I'm confused why are you not in
the center weird it's very weird oh of
course
yeah so thanks to the center is that so
we need to set it through like well if
you wanted to be in the center we can
just set it to 41.5 so
hmm pretty cool almost looks like
there's a bit of a lens flare as well
cool effect huh so there we go that
should demonstrate the chatters are
working pretty well cool any questions
leave them in the comments below
all this will be on github of course and
the next episode should probably be
tomorrow
ish we'll see anyway hope you guys
enjoyed this episode please don't forget
to hit the like button if you did enjoy
it and I'll see you guys next time
goodbye
you